[Music]
I can't believe I'm working for Bruce
Wayne Bruce Wayne's husband
I told him about you powerless it's
finally coming yeah oh it's happening
I'm excited to watch it myself because
I'm always cracking up on set I feel
like I'm really gonna actually enjoy
watching the show we haven't seen you
play such a wholesome role since your
high school musical role it was I like
to step back into those goody two-shoes
silly goody two-shoes she's just very
ambitious and very confident that she
can make a change in the world and I
think that's a really wonderful thing to
be able to tap into that well you made
one of my dreams come true by teaming
back up with Ashley Tisdale and singing
X's and O's it went viral
you know please have some more duets
from you please things are a little busy
right now my paralyzed but uh somewhere
down the line and we thought it would be
so much fun we loved each other so much
so are you gonna be going big for
Valentine's Day this year what are your
plan I don't know Austin's gonna be in
New Zealand because he's working on his
show shannara chronicles' so I don't
know maybe we'll do like a sister's
romantic situation maybe spawn dinner
you and Austin have such an amazing
relationship what is the secret to
staying so connected when you film so
far apart I think communication in any
relationship whether it's friendships or
romantically it's it's key
you